my fear in life is balding is it i can't
be fat and bald
you know what i'm saying dude listen dog
when you're fat you got to pick
struggles very intelligently theo really
yeah man i don't get to be you know you
can have a kind of a smelly day and get
away with it because you're an old
handsome [ __ ] not me damn if i'm fat
and smelly it sticks forever i gotta
make sure i am smelling my daughter yeah
if you wake up forget deodorant should i
hope a little musty i wake up and forget
deodorant that'll log it's a damn
ecosystem oh dude
i will it will follow me like pig pen oh
you'll have a loss on the north side
i can't be fat and bald man yeah yeah
cause you're a bigger guy man what's it
like being bigger well you got to make
sure every chair won't hurt you or break
you you look first thing well you've got
to give it the test you know what i'm
saying for sure you got to ease into it
yeah damn i don't think about that kind
of stuff and were you always a big guy
since you were young yeah dude i was fat
as a kid man i've just always struggled
with like
and i think it's a part of my my
personal mental health struggles right
we all have our own things and our own
demons and vices and for me
i could literally go on a three-day
cocaine bender right now and wake up on
the fourth day and be like well that was
a lot of fun and not do it again for
weeks or months you know
but dude you [ __ ] set some snacks out
somewhere and don't let me hover around
more than two or three minutes i'll
start filling my pockets up like i'm in
jail and i'm never gonna see them again
yeah i'm saying like for sure you want
them snacks yeah yeah i'm all about
snacks does it scare your way does it
worry you yeah all the time dude i don't
want to be this fat hell i don't want
people commenting on who's going to die
it's going to happen for sure you know
what i mean i'll tell ya it might be me
writing it too
you know it's like you don't want to go
through that and yeah i'm on the i got a
nutritionist now i've been working on
working on my weight this year more than
i have in a long time
but i also don't worry about as much as
i should because i've been on this
roller coaster my whole life
where i'm a little more plump right now
but i can show you pictures when i was
less plump and i could show you pictures
when i was more plump i just kind of you
know it's kind of part of what what i
deal with just trying to get on the
other side of the mountain i know they
do a lot of those surgeries and so if
you ever done anything like that where
they like get into your system or
whatever yeah i'm just not with that
don't you know i'm not gonna i don't
know man don't [ __ ] don't get cut on and
all that old [ __ ] yeah
yeah i just don't know what people do
you you know what the most selfish thing
i can say right now is what's real
i've heard when you do the surgery it
[ __ ] with your ability to intake
anything
which i would love for that to be the
case with food but like they were like
well you can't drink more than a half
gallon of water a day on her it'll make
you sick
what like i don't want to spend my life
i'd rather die young yeah not young like
this but like you know then having to
measure your water you have to measure
my water you know what i'm saying
like just little stuff like
yeah when they started explaining some
of the stuff to me because i went and
talked to the dude you know what i mean
like there's no there's not a fat person
on earth that can afford the surgery
that hasn't at least went and talked to
the person about the surgery yeah you
know and when he started explaining it
to me i was just like and he was honest
enough too he's like look man
i think that if you just put your mind
to it you'll lose the weight again it's
been proven that you can lose the weight
what hasn't been proven is that i can
keep the weight off
so that's what we gotta figure out next
that's such a struggle for so many
people man you know i i i don't know
what that's like i know what the
struggle is like but i don't know what
that struggle is like do you feel though
also
you're so recognizable as this like
larger than life character
do you feel like being larger
you almost have to be larger no it's
like
i think the real side of it is
it's a decision to live
and i'm just starting to make that
decision
i spent most of my life yeah not giving
a [ __ ] if i live or not just not giving
a [ __ ] i feel like i mean like i tell
people to this day like when i really
start to get angry
i have to i've had to have this moment
with a few grown men in my life where
i'm like dog do i look like somebody
that cares
like you should really assess that
before you talk to me crazy
i have everything written on my body to
show you i don't give a [ __ ] about a lot
you know what i mean it's like i'm just
starting to give a [ __ ] like i'm just
looking at my 14 year old daughter like
i used to be like if i could just live
till she's 18 i'd be okay now i'm
starting to be like i'd like to meet my
grandkids i think yeah you know it's
like you're starting to think about [ __ ]
you didn't think about before isn't that
kind of magical when those ideas come in
your head that think make you believe
you care about yourself yes that's
insane it's little stuff that's like i
think i do want to meet my grandchildren
yeah so that's what made me higher in
nutrition is before it was like a chore
to be like i just want to stay alive
till she's 18 so i don't create any more
unnecessary trauma in her life yeah you
know what i'm saying and then it's like
you know it's about her and then it's
kind of like selfishly now it's about me
it's like i don't know man i kind of
want to hang out with your grandkids i
kind of want to kind of want to see
where this thing ends up with her yeah i
want to see what jelly yeah when jelly
starts to kind of coagulate i want to be
there yeah for sure i want to kind of
look because like now she's cool enough
at 14 that i'm like dude i bet she's
going to kick ass at 25. i want to see
that yeah you know what i'm saying like
oh dude she's going to be a whole
different human at 35. [ __ ] i didn't
know my ear for my [ __ ] at 25. wait
till she's 35 i'm like [ __ ] i gotta live
for 30 years not 20. you know what i
mean like oh god damn i need to damn i'm
gonna have to [ __ ] stay alive i'm
gonna have to do a push-off or something
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one